ben conjoint là dessus pascal mathieu
vice président québec de la croix rouge
canadienne bonsoir monsieur mathieu
bonsoir
alors parlons un peu de ce qui se passe
en ce moment là le gouvernement a
annoncé une aide financière pour
permettre à terme l'embauchent dans
l'essai chez celles des 2 900 personnes
qui seront formés par vous par la croix
rouge
vous avez tous dans le processus de
recrutement on recrute en forme
on se prépare la premier première équipe
sur le terrain
le 6 juillet alors présentement on a le
7 juillet on doit déployer 150 personnes
des 150 personnes ont déjà été engagés
ils commencent leur formation lundi et
la semaine suivante ce sera 150 de plus
alors on recrues on a reçu quand même
déjà beaucoup de descriptions non mais
encore la population havre où il ya de
la douleur goût mais on a eu quelques
milliers d'applications mais c'est pas
tout le monde qui applique va se rendre
jusqu'au bout avons encore besoin on
encore de la place
donc ce qu'on cherche c'est des gens
dynamiques idéalement en bonne santé pas
c'est quand même un travail ardu et avec
l'atlant son amant alors c'est
l'occasion unique pour ceux qui veulent
faire une mission humanitaire avec la
croix rouge sans quitter québec et vous
dites travail ardu
c'est exactement ce que faisait les
membres des forces armées
ce que vont faire ces personnes
éventuellement pris c'est exactement le
même travail d'ailleurs c'est nous à la
croix rouge qui vont former les
militaires avant leur déploiement
alors donc le mystère de la santé
appelle ce rôle là est de service
c'est la personne qui assiste un préposé
aux bénéficiaires sa demande pas de
formation obligatoire nous on va donner
quelques journées de formation trois ou
quatre jours tout le monde on les
prépare et donc la tâche essentiellement
amener les plateaux de repas aider des
gens ne sont autonomes à s'alimenter
enlever la vaisselle la ramener changer
parfois des droits faire un peu de
nettoyage ça prend des gens pour
accompagner les bénéficiaires les gens
qui vivent dans les services élevé
lorsqu'ils se déplacent à celle juste
genre de fonction là tout sous la
supervision du personnel médical déjà
des gestes qui font la différence on
devient au cours des dernières semaines
maintenant vous mentionnez que tout se
met en branle véritablement à partir du
6 juillet mais d'ici là qu'est ce qui se
passe
il ya bien sûr la crise
on en est simple oui mais j'ai été mes
collègues et moi est en conversation à
tous les jours répètent les militaires
puis nous assure et j'entendais plus tôt
le général le dire dans une entrevue
les sièges à celle d où l'armée est
présente les militaires vont s'assurer
de ne sortir que lorsque l'endroit sera
classé vert par l'eau devant dames en
ski airplay là on est en discussion avec
le ministère de la santé note qui nous
indique où on va aller ce qu'on pensait
qu'on va aller dans d'autres cherchent à
celle d où les militaires ne seront pas
des endroits où il ya d'autres besoins
qui n'ont pas été couverts maintenant ce
qui jusqu'à l'horizon ce qui se profile
à l'horizon et monsieur erdal disait il
ya des très fortes de très fortes
chances qu'il survienne une deuxième
vague ceci le prochain grand défi est ce
que la croix rouge et les personnes que
vous allez former sont équipés pour
faire face à tout ça oui pardon c'est
aussi la raison pourquoi on le fait vous
savez il ya encore des besoins dans les
sièges celle des keys employés qui sont
là sont épuisés mais où certains
employés sont épuisés dans votre travail
et l'envoi de ton temps de les aider
mais en même temps c'est aussi notre
façon de se préparer le deuxième vague
j'en profiterai pour dire que la croix
rouge est déjà dans les sièges celle des
depuis plus de deux mois il ya deux mois
et demi le message de la santé nous a
demandé en urgence qui a eu les grandes
explosions ce qu'on pouvait faire pour
aider alors tout d'abord nous déployer
notre hôpital de campagne à la salsa ce
cas mariale mais surtout on a rapatrié
nos experts des gens de croix rouge
canadienne qui vont combattre les
terrible épidémie d'ebola choléra en
afrique et ailleurs dans le monde on les
aurait pas prier chez nous dont les à
déployer on a déjà travaillé dans 55 ch
sld la plupart d'entre eux en crise par
la discussion qu'on avec le médecin ceux
qui désireront continue sur le terrain
ce qu'on fait maintenant c'est qu'on
visite bch sld qui ne sont pas en crise
soit pour les aider soit pour donner des
conseils et surtout pour les préparer à
la deuxième vague
le ministère de la santé nous a aussi
demandé de préparer des formations pour
leurs personnels afin qu'ils profitent
de l'expérience qu'on a acquis en
afrique dans le pays mais aussi pendant
les deux derniers mois dans les cercles
celle des jeux tout ça est prévu
jusqu'au 15 septembre mais ça pourrait
aller au delà c'est pour avoir un
prolongement de ce soutien là dessus
qu'on premier tout à fait pour l'instant
on embauche d
qui sont disponibles pour l'été jusqu'au
15 septembre mais vous savez avec l'aco
vue de la coved nous a déjà réservé
beaucoup de surprises
il peut y en avoir d'autres on se
prépare pour la prochaine vague verra
conseille juste trop besoin
il faudra il faudra effectivement merci
beaucoup pascal mathieu je rappelle vice
président québec de la croix rouge
canadienne